[Música]
el ministerio de defensa de ucrania
informó que un total de 264 militares
por fin pudieron ser evacuados de la
planta de shocks tal en la ciudad de
mariupol entretanto al menos 20 civiles
entre ellos un niño murieron en medio de
bombardeos registrados en las regiones
ucranianas de donets y lugansk
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
anunció que restablecerá los vuelos
comerciales con cuba que suspenderá el
límite a las remesas
de igual forma restablecerá el programa
de reunificación familiar así el
mandatario da marcha atrás a algunas de
las medidas más duras impulsadas por
donald trump
méxico superó las 100.000 personas
registradas como desaparecidas según los
datos oficiales una de cada tres
víctimas se ha registrado durante la
administración del presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador por lo que las
organizaciones sociales llaman
enérgicamente a que se priorice la
atención a esta problemática tenemos
reporte desde ciudad de mexico
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentina torre sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en ucrania donde
la ofensiva rusa continúa centrada en el
este del país las autoridades de kiev
denunciaron que 20 civiles perdieron la
vida en medio de bombardeos registrados
en las regiones de donestsk y lugansk
entretanto en mariupol el ministerio de
defensa de ucrania indicó que más de 260
militares fueron evacuados de la planta
de a soft al 53 de ellos heridos de
gravedad así se pronunció el presidente
volodymyr selenski al respecto
en cuanto a la situación en mariupol
gracias a las acciones del ejército
ucraniano las fuerzas armadas de ucrania
la inteligencia el grupo de negociación
el comité internacional de la cruz roja
y la onu esperamos poder salvar la vida
de nuestros muchachos entre ellos hay
heridos graves se les da cuidado quiero
enfatizar que ucrania necesita héroes
ucranianos vivos ese es nuestro
principio dichoso el presidente turco
recep tayip erdogán aseguró que vetará
el ingreso de suecia y finlandia a la
otan esto luego de que los gobiernos de
ambas naciones anunciarán que
presentarán la solicitud formal de
adhesión a la alianza el mandatario
turco calificó a suecia textualmente
como un centro de incubación de
organizaciones terroristas el secretario
general de la otan jens stoltenberg
aseguró que cualquier preocupación de
seguridad de turquía será tratada
la delegación a su equipo y la cndh esa
vendrán a turquía el lunes vienen a
convencernos disculpen
por humos pero no deberían gastar
energía
porque
en primer lugar no aceptaríamos que
quienes imponen sanciones a turquía se
unan a la otan ya
por qué entonces la otan dejaría de ser
una organización de seguridad y se
convertiría en un lugar donde se
concentran los representantes de las
organizaciones terroristas exterior
histeria arte está a pocas semanas de
las elecciones parlamentarias de francia
el presidente de manuel manjón eligió a
elisabeth bone como primera ministra
tras la renuncia de jan castex band con
un perfil social y ecológico en hubble
son el pasado de las cátedras de trabajo
y medioambiente pero su nombramiento
genera rechazo entre algunos sectores
políticos de cara a los comicios de
junio ella aseguró que se necesitan
acciones más veloces y fuertes para
luchar contra el cambio climático y se
comprometió a trabajar para proteger el
poder adquisitivo de los franceses
el presidente de eeuu joe biden anunció
que restablecerá los vuelos comerciales
con cuba y que levantara el límite a las
remesas actualmente establecido en un
máximo de 1000 dólares trimestrales
de igual forma restablecerá el programa
de reunificación familiar con estas
decisiones el mandatario da marcha atrás
a algunas de las medidas más duras
impulsadas por donald trump según el
gobierno estadounidense estas medidas
buscan mostrar apoyo al pueblo cubano
darle herramientas para conseguir una
vida libre previamente conversamos con
cristóbal vázquez corresponsal de france
24 en washington que nos indicó porque
la administración bailén toma esta
decisión en estos momentos y la relación
que tiene con la crisis migratoria en la
frontera mexicana
precisamente ese es el tema que muchos
analistas están diciendo es el tema
central en esta decisión de iovine en el
tema migratorio y es que nunca se habían
presentado más cubanos en la frontera
entre eeuu y méxico desde
1980 son cerca de 32 mil cubanos que han
intentado cruzar la frontera sólo en el
mes de abril duplicando la cifra de
febrero y esto pues llama mucho la
atención y obviamente prende las alertas
acá en eeuu porque hay precisamente en
juba una crisis política y económica de
grandes magnitudes que está haciendo que
los cubanos salgan de la isla
precisamente por el apretón que durante
varios años sufrieron los cubanos por
parte de la administración de donald
trump entonces lo que están diciendo
muchos analistas es que estas nuevas
medidas estas levantamiento de estas
restricciones lo que buscan es ayudar a
que los cubanos se queden es la isla
tengan un poco más de oportunidades y
pues se replante en la decisión de a
través de panamá nicaragua o mexico
tratar de llegar a eeuu y evitar
entonces creciera aún más la crisis
migratoria que vive eeuu en su frontera
en mexico en las cifras oficiales
exponen que ya son más de 100 miles las
personas desaparecidas los datos
muestran que una de cada tres víctimas
de este flagelo han desaparecido durante
el gobierno de andrés manuel lópez
obrador desde ciudad de méxico mario
carbonell nos amplió los detalles
méxico supera este 16 de mayo la barrera
de las 100.000 personas desaparecidas y
no localizadas así lo reporta el propio
registro nacional del sistema nacional
de búsqueda a este respecto se han
pronunciado colectivos de defensa de
derechos humanos como el centro miguel
agustín pro y también el propio consejo
ciudadano del sistema nacional de
búsqueda conformado por los familiares
de las víctimas y por especialistas
quienes exigen que se aplique ya una
política pública de estado para frenar
las desapariciones forzadas en este país
el propio comité contra la desaparición
forzada de naciones unidas- cuyos
integrantes estuvieron de visita en
abril pasado advirtieron que la
desaparición forzada en méxico es el
crimen perfecto por el grado de
impunidad que se registra hay esfuerzos
por parte del gobierno a través del
subsecretario de derechos humanos
alejandro encinas y de la comisionada
nacional de búsqueda carla quintana así
como por parte del congreso al aprobar
recientemente el centro nacional de
identificación humana todo ello para
ayudar a combatir este flagelo
se vive en distintos puntos podemos ver
colectivos de madres buscadoras en son
ahora en nuevo léon en coahuila en
morelos veracruz guerrero en fin por
todas partes del país buscando a sus
desaparecidos además esto se suma a los
más de 52 mil cuerpos que hay sin
identificar en el país lo que da cuenta
de que los esfuerzos aún son
insuficientes
pasamos a colombia donde la guerrilla de
la ln anunció un alto el fuego por la
primera vuelta presidencial en el país
el autodenominado ejército de liberación
nacional señaló en un comunicado que el
cese de hostilidades entra en vigor el
próximo 25 de mayo y finaliza el 3 de
junio en el texto del grupo indicó
además que pese al silencio de los
fusiles se reserva el derecho de
defenderse en caso de ser atacado en el
mismo comunicado la guerrilla reitera su
disposición de restablecer el proceso de
paz que la administración de iván duque
suspendió en 2019
finalizamos en chile la convención
constitucional presentó ante la comisión
de armonización el borrador oficial de
la nueva carta magna dicho organismo es
el encargado de realizar la corrección
final del documento que consta de 499
artículos y que posteriormente será
sometido a plebiscito la norma tiene que
estar lista en julio patricia luna
corresponsal de france 24 en santiago
nos explicó cuáles son los principales
aspectos del borrador presentado y sus
diferencias respecto a la constitución
actual con este primer borrador
presentado por la convención
constitucional de ser aprobado en el
plebiscito de salida chile pasaría de
ser un estado subsidiario a un estado
garante de derechos sociales
democráticos es también un estado que se
reconoce como plurinacional es decir
reconoce la existencia de los pueblos
originarios que están muy presentes en
este primer borrador desde la
constitución y también su carácter
intercultural además de ecológico los
aspectos de defensa del medio ambiente
están también muy presentes en este
nuevo borrador en el que también hay
aspectos polémicos como puede ser
ejemplo el derecho al aborto que aunque
nuestra de forma explícita si está
contenido en la constitución otros
aspectos que han generado polémica
además del aspecto plurinacional es la
existencia del sistema judicial para las
comunidades indígenas que se aplicaría
en ciertos aspectos en ciertas normas y
que estaría siempre bajo la garantía del
tribunal constitucional del tribunal
supremo que tendría la última palabra
estos son algunos de los aspectos más
destacados en una constitución que
también eliminaría el senado y lo
sustituye a por una cámara de regiones
en el que las regiones y la
descentralización del poder del chile
estaría mucho más presente es todo por
el momento en france 24 les agradecemos
su sintonía continúen con nosotros que
volvemos en breve
[Música]